of course everyone's still talking about
the Supreme Court's historic decision to
legalize same-sex marriage right after
right after Friday's ruling a few
corporations decided to show their
support right away for example this is
true American Airlines posted this image
online with rainbows on every screen
which I thought don't let people thought
that was like a nice gesture it was
American Airlines saying yes we're
behind this decision we think this is
great and over the weekend is
interesting other companies
saw that so they started jumping on the
pro-gay bandwagon for example cialis has
altered its image of a couple holding
hands in a bathtub to this check out the
new cialis ad I thought that was
fascinating
[Music]
Oh snuggle laundry detergent had their
mascot hang out with some other bears
[Applause]
I'm happy finally there was this image
from the usually anti-gay company
chick-fil-a they put this out we were
wrong wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]